Smart TVs everyone's got them I still
have an old-fashioned dumb TV but the
Smart TV is they're big you know they're
internet connected you can get Roku on
there an Apple TV and all that fancy
stuff
well Samsung has a Smart TV that lets
you use voice recognition so you can
talk to the TV tell it what you want to
watch volume up volume down channels etc
etc the only problem is the TV might be
listening to you and sending your
information to third parties Samsung has
released a statement okay so on the left
I'm gonna read you part of the statement
and then I'm gonna go to the famous book
1984 so the highlight on the left please
be aware that if your spoken words
include personal or other sensitive
information that information will be
among the data captured and transmitted
to a third party through use of your
voice recognition so let's just take a
moment in and think about that for a
second I mean what they're saying is
that if you're talking in front of your
TV even if you're not giving it commands
there is a chance that they're listening
this television is listening and sending
it to third parties not good that
doesn't seem good to me all right now
let's look at an excerpt from 1984 any
sound that Winston made above the level
of a low whisper would be picked up by
it moreover so long as he remained
within the field of vision which the
metal plaque commanded he could be seen
as well as heard there was of course no
way of knowing whether you were being
watched at any given moment how often or
on what system the thought police
plugged in on any individual wire was
guesswork that is basically what's
happening I don't know if you've been
watching this show for a while but we
also talked a lot about the NSA hackers
anonymous information Google emails all
of this stuff it's all kind of connected
you know even your iPhone where you now
put your fingerprint in your iPhone it's
like we know all this stuff is being
stolen we know and we're literally
buying the products the phones and then
we're buying the televisions to put them
in our houses with these kind of
security flaws what do you make of this
this is a scary chip I'm turning into a
great old man I was no man when I was
six yeah so like you know when kids are
painting class and be like stop man you
getting it on your clothes is weird
but no so when it comes to Vegas I'm
late
on the technology upgrades because I
just don't like them and I don't think
specifically and go you know that TV's
gonna record us and take us to a third
party I don't think that way I just
think I don't need it
yeah whatever reason just intrinsic that
I don't need it like pushing the button
on the remote it's plenty easy for me so
I don't it didn't appeal to me that I
can speak to my TV at any time it's
gonna pick up and change the channel for
me I didn't want any of that
so in Cygnus it just it just you know it
galvanizes my my disbelief in this type
of technology standard I mean no I'm not
lying to you I just got into the whole
the downloading of music and spotify and
all that I was like the CD is beautiful
said the downloading I want to see the
murder trial that happens with Samsung
gets a confession through their
television if they then turn over to the
cops I mean this is terrifying this and
what's the worst thing is that they're
gonna make more and more sets like this
and it's going to become that thing
where it's like the the itunes agreement
that no one reads we all click I agree
that ultimately it looks like we just
it's this it's been the slow erosion of
how much are we willing to take yeah and
at first you know there's this oh my god
that's terrible and then eventually like
okay fine so you know it's like first
everything cuz there were people who are
like oh my god Facebook is gonna own all
my photos and I was like yeah right so
isn't that the staggering part that it's
the slow erosion but it's in everything
that we do I mean look we're all walking
around with phones on us now if your
television can be listening to you even
if your phone's not on I think about
this sometimes even if your phone is not
on but it's in your pocket so I don't I
would imagine that some pretty fancy
hackers somewhere could figure out a way
for your phone not to light up and
somehow them be getting the audio or
whatever it is so this just to sell you
[ __ ] that's the thing it's not even half
the time it's not even for the NSA or
whatever it's just to tell you so that's
that's interesting point so it's not
necessarily for purposes of spying or
evil in that way so should we take some
comfort in that it's maybe just to sell
us know we should that that's the
surfacing that's how as you mentioned
that's how they get us to buy the yeah
that's the way to get us do it for our
own better transmitters
so like so when it comes to like this
the selling point is your life is easier
just speak to your TV you don't depress
the butt anymore but as we read deep in
the article about this
there was a disclaimer from Samsung
saying hey by the way if you don't want
it to be listening to you and take in
your conversations
and then suddenly see new products that
you didn't want then you're all you do
is turn it off right hit that go to this
menu and push that and go to that menu
and then go and change it and then if
you want to back on go and change again
um at the end of the day this sounds
more complicated than what I was doing
with yes we're so confused but it
actually gets harder if you know what
you taking everything in you're a
hundred percent my parents have this TV
the Samsung TV they cannot use the voice
recognition thing there's no way I don't
even think they can use a remote
properly and I every time I go home I
end up spending three hours I don't
charge them the hourly rate pro bono but
I think you're making a good point that
so they so samsung says okay you can
shut this thing off but I think 99% of
people a most people unfortunately just
give away their privacy regardless so
they don't think about it but then the
rest of the people they don't even they
wouldn't take the time to really figure
out how to do it I always bring up the
the seminal film Charlie's Angels where
the whole big villain plot of that movie
was that they would be able to track all
of our cellphones and know where we were
at any given moment and then a couple
years later Foursquare happened and we
just didn't ourselves we voluntarily did
it ourselves we check in on Facebook we
check in on Yelp or whatever and it's
like yeah we're perfectly happy to just
give that away and to bring this to our
earlier segments on the superhero movies
in the second Batman with Heath Ledger
as the Joker because they used all the
cellphones to as sonar to be able to
track him and blah blah blah anyway
we're in a lot of [ __ ] people what do
you think let us know in the comments
right down